[Musique]
ça ratisse bonsoir ce soir on va vous
raconter notre changement de vie complet
qui a duré deux ans en fait en 2015 en
habiter à camp delhi avait son
entreprise moi j'étais chirurgien à
l'hôpital
on avait nos trois enfants à quand tout
allait très bien on était bien et on a
décidé d'aller servir les autres d'aller
aider nos qu'on a pris une année entière
pour réfléchir pour se former avec une
ong qui s'appelle fidesco au bout de
cette année on a dit oui pour partir
deux ans et fidesco nous a donné deux
missions l'ailier est parti dans un
réseau d'hôpitaux avec 14 hôpitaux
trente maternités 150 dispensaire au
départ elle a été responsable des
services techniques photovoltaïque
fabrication distribution de médicaments
et dans un second temps elle a pris la
direction de tout le réseau
moi je suis partie en tant que
chirurgien pour travailler comme
chirurgien est formé des des congolais à
la chirurgie dans un hôpital local et
ils nous envoyaient à bukavu dans le
kivu alors les kivu vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler
si c'est le cas c'est grâce au docteur
mukwege et le prix nobel de la paix de
cette année qu'on appelle aussi le
réparateur des femmes réparateur des
femmes
pascoe qui vous le viol est une arme de
guerre peut-être aussi vous avez entendu
la dernière épidémie d'ebola ou alors
vous avez regardé l'émission du sang
dans vos portables
bref le kivu comme ça ça fait pas rêver
et pourtant c'est une région sublime qui
se trouve à l'est de la république
démocratique du congo dans la région des
grands lacs à la frontière avec le
rwanda et le burundi
c'est une région absolument merveilleuse
où il ya un climat parfait il fait 25
degrés toute l'année donc jamais trop
chaud jamais froid il ya des pluies
chaque jour il fait beau tous les jours
donc en fait ce sont des centaines de
collines verdoyantes
qui se jette dans le lac qui a donné son
nom à la région
là je vous décris un jardin d'éden mais
dans le sous-sol de jardin il ya
énormément de minerai et en particulier
de l'or et du coltan le coltan c'est le
minerai qu'on utilise pour faire nos
smartphones et de tablettes
alors ça alimente des guerres
incessantes avec des milices armées qui
violent qui pillent qui tue entre 98 et
2008 on estime à cinq millions le nombre
de personnes décédées des guerres ou de
ses conséquences
5 millions ça représente deux fois le
nombre de français qui sont décédés
pendant la première et la dernière est
la deuxième guerre mondiale
alors forcément quand on a dit qu'on
partait au kivu en famille
les gens nous ont pris pour des fous et
c'est vrai qu'une mère de famille qui
emmène ses trois enfants là bas on peut
se dire soit qu'il est complètement
irresponsable soit au pire qu'elle est
suicidaire mais voilà première fois on a
décidé de faire autre chose que ce que
les gens attendaient de nous c'est vrai
que ça a été compliqué d'annoncer ce
départ est de communiquer dessus on n'a
pas pu communiquer parce que c'était une
décision qui reposait sur notre foi et
au travail
ça s'est passé un peu pareil les jeunes
nous ont dit mais tu es complètement
malade tu vas pas lâcher sa boîte tu vas
pas lâcher ta carrière
si tu veux aider les jambes tu peux les
aider ici et puis si tu vas aller bosser
deux en afrique plus personne plus
personne ne voudra bosser avec toi quand
tu reviendras bon c'était compliqué de
communiquer mais on a décidé quand même
de prendre nos valises et de partir pour
arriver là bas on est passé par le
rwanda m on a passé la frontière entre
le rwanda et le congo donc et en fait
c'est un petit pont en bois sur une
rivière avec nos valises à la main
et on arrivait dans un univers
complètement différents tout était né
complètement différent donc 1,6 million
d'habitants à bukavu
tout le monde est habillé avec des
pagnes hyper colorés c'est super
chouette les gens tirent des espèces de
charette les voitures sont complètement
déglingué il n'y a pas de route donc
quand il pleut ben c'est la boue partout
et puis quand il fait beau c'est de la
poussière partout
on a mis nos enfants à l'école donc on
avait trois petits blancs dans une école
où il y avait 2500 noir tout le monde
les regardait tout le monde voulait
toucher tout le monde était agglutinée
autos étaient tous en uniforme
impeccable et ils étaient tous rangés
bien tous les matins pour la levée du
drapeau congolais avec l'hymne national
il était sage parce que les maîtres il
avait la chicotte chikhates c'est un
bâton pour frapper les élèves qui sont
pas sages
donc autant vous dire que nos enfants a
été particulièrement sage pendant deux
ans on s'est installés aussi dans une
nouvelle maison donc la maison c'est pas
pareil qu'ici il n'y a pas d'eau donc
faut aller chercher l'eau avec des
bidons et puis on peut pas se doucher
n'y a pas de show donc cédé douche
froide
on prend un seau et puis on se lave
comme ça et pour faire la cuisine c'est
compliqué aussi pour soi des amis à
dîner et j'amène un coq vivant
donc il faut tuer le coq quand tu le coq
il faut le plus mais il faut le vider il
faut le préparer mais pour le préparer
il faut le faire sur un feu donc il faut
avoir du charbon pour faire le brasero
et puis faire cuire le poulet il faut se
dépêcher parce qu'à 18h comme on a pas
d'électricité fait nuit donc c'est
compliqué et on se retrouve à mam ont
dîné ensemble et puis s'il ya des restes
bas on les met pas au frigo n'est pas de
frigo et puis si jamais on a un rester
on peut pas le réchauffé deux minutes au
micro n'y a pas de micro ondes non plus
et donc on a changé notre regard sur
notre quotidien et et puis sur les
autres aussi oui notre regard sur les
autres a changé et aussi le regard que
les autres portent est sûre nous prenons
par exemple les canons de beauté
féminins en france ses évidentes nous
leur envoie une belle femme c'est une
femme mince au congo c'est pas du tout
ça
une belle femme elle est ronde voire
très rondes et c'est comme ça que mes
amis quand elle voulait me faire plaisir
elle me disait pas l'iata bonne mine où
les lire tu as une jolie robe non pas du
tout amusé lelia tu as bien grossi
évidemment ça ne faisait pas super
plaisir
chat c'est non non on regarde bien j'ai
un gros signe 6 il faut que tu sois
belle faut que tu prennes encore 10 kg
bon je les ai pas fait changer d'avis là
dessus mais c'est vrai que du coup
pendant ces deux ans nous avons été
complètement libérée du regard que les
autres portent et sur nous parce qu'en
tant qu'étranger tout ce qu'on faisait
était tellement bizarre que finalement
il y avait plus d'attentes sur ce qu'on
avait à faire ou pas et donc on pouvait
se permettre d'être complètement nous
mêmes et puis on s'adapte et je vais
vous raconter quelques anecdotes pour
vous montrer comment on s'adapte je
compte du travail un soir et on habite à
un tout petit appartement dans une
procurer donc il y avait pas de cuisine
il y avait une cuisine commune au
rez-de-chaussée et j'entends la jeune
fille qui s'occupe de nos enfants qui
parlent avec un petit enfant congolais
tu tiens il ya un an
maintenant qu'ils habitent ici avec nous
je rentre dans la cuisine pour voir qui
c'est et je vois mon fils parler à la
jeune fille avec un accent congolais à
couper au couteau
j'aurais jamais reconnu la voix de mon
enfant au congo pareil c'est tout à fait
normal de marcher dans la rue entre
hommes pour se promener et donc la
première fois qu'un ami détiennent a
voulu lui prendre la main pour se
promener dans la rue
il est à houla là mais qu'est ce qui me
fait celui-là il est bizarre au bout de
deux ans ils étaient doigts entrelacés
avec ses amis sur le trottoir ça lui
posait plus aucun problème en fait voilà
on s'est tellement imprégnés de cette
culture que on a même été souvent
surpris en voyant notre reflet se dire
ah non en fait je suis blanc on va un
petit peu parler d'argent
nous on est parti pour donner deux ans
donc avant de partir on a vendu
l'appartement majorité de nos affaires
on a résilié tout ce qu'on avait
assurance abonnements etc etc et on est
parti on n'a pas gagné d'argent donc on
avait un compte en banque sans aucun
mouvement pendant deux ans ça c'est cool
là bas on avait quand même une indemnité
de subsistance en liquide on avait 300
dollars et du coup avec 300 dollars par
mois en famille eh ben on compte chaque
dollar
il a fallu qu'on fasse avec est alors en
france quand on a envie de lui paire de
baskets on l'achète pas forcément parce
qu'on a parce que c'est utile parce
qu'on en a besoin on peut l'acheter
parce qu'on en a juste envie eh bien là
aussi un enfant lé basket trouée dans
l'elysée c'est bientôt l'anniversaire
filera bukavu c'est aussi faire
l'expérience du danger il est 17 heures
je rentre avec mes collaborateurs du
travail je conduis un land cruiser blanc
donc j'ai un des collaborateurs à ma
droite et deux derrière
à 17 heures on est sur la rue principale
de bukavu ça grouille de monde
il ya des vendeurs partout au bord de la
route et tout le monde se presse de
faire ces dernières courses avant la
tombée de la nuit à 18 heures tout à
coup sûr ma gauche il ya une énorme
explosion
et ça se met à tirer à tirer à tirer mes
collègues hurle baisse toi je me mets
derrière le volant et je me mets à
piloter comme un pilote de formule 1
pour nous sortir de cette mauvaise passe
on se réfugie dans un petit supermarché
plus loin où etienne nous attendait et
son confrère l'appel pour nous dire que
le changeur de monnaie qui a reçu une
grenade dans les jambes vient de perdre
ses deux jambes et qu'il le prend en
charge
c'est aussi quelques semaines après il
est 5 heures du matin etienne est pas là
il est à goma la ville au nord du lac
pour une mission pour l'institut
français et j'entends que ça tire on a
l'habitude
donc je sors vite de notre petit
appartement parce que nos deux aînés
donne dans une chambre sur la coursive
donc je vais les chercher et je me mets
avec nos trois enfants contre les murs
loin des fenêtres sous des matelas on
entend les tirs de carabine de l'armée
congolaise
jusque là c'est plutôt normal sauf que
cette fois ce qui leur répond c'est des
mitrailleuses
on comprend que ça va durer longtemps et
puis après les mitrailleuses
c'est les tirs de mortier c'est les
roquettes
on entend la détonation ça siffle et on
est absolument incapable de savoir où
est-ce que ça va tomber si ça va être
sur nous si ça va être sur les voisins
la terre tremble et ça recommence ça va
durer 12 heures
bizarrement pendant ces 12 heures
j'ai pas eu si peur que ça et j'avais
l'intimé conviction que j'étais au bon
endroit à l'endroit où je devais être en
cet instant précis j'ai pas compris tout
de suite pourquoi j'avais cette
conviction large déçu quand on est parti
au bout de nos deux ans de missions nos
amis nous ont dit vous savez vous on a
su que vous veniez pas pour piller le
congo parce que quand ça a chauffé à
bukavu
vous n'avez pas fui avec les autres
blancs vous êtes resté avec nous moi
j'ai plus de difficulté sur sur mon
quotidien au travail pour vous recadre
et quand on travaille à l'hôpital en
france on reçoit régulièrement des
histoires qui sont durs et des drames
humains et savent que en france on a de
la chance parce que entre deux drames
humains il se passe un temps suffisant
pour qu'on puisse se reconstruire et
finalement garder notre carapace de
chirurgiens là-bas en fait la situation
est vraiment différente et on reçoit
tous les jours voire plusieurs fois par
jour des drames humains donc cessé d
enfants qui sont tombés dans la marmite
d'huile bouillante c'est et y cuisine
avec des braseros milieu de la pièce
commune et tous les enfants courent à au
tour donc il n'arrête pas de se brûler
et puis sont pas soignés tout de suite
donc ils reviennent avec les membres des
formes et avec les cicatrices il y en a
ils ont des fractures ouvertes depuis un
an deux ans et
ils arrivent à l'hôpital ils ont déjà un
membre en état de décomposition il ya ya
ya un bus lui à 20 30 personnes dedans
qui tombe dans un ravin donc ils sont
tous gravement blessé puis arrive à
l'hôpital ensemble et puis puis en plus
ils sont nus parce qu'ils se sont fait
piller avant de se faire se courir dans
ces temps il ya des familles peuvent
plus payer les soins pour leurs enfants
et donc les enfants sont plus soignés et
ça peut durer longtemps
en fait il ya une accumulation d'émotion
il ya beaucoup de tristesse de colère et
de sentiment d'injustice et et en fait
on n'a pas le temps de la reconstruction
entre deux drames humains qui arrivent
dans nos mains alors du coup ben moi
c'est arrivé au bout de mes limites
clairement donc j'ai appris à pleurer
j'ai appris à pleurer tout seul dans mon
coin puis avec mes collègues et puis
avec les patients aussi alors on a posé
beaucoup de gestes techniques
on a fait beaucoup de reconstruction de
membres on n'est pas bon de très très
bons résultats
mais au-delà de ce geste technique
en fait moi ce que j'ai vraiment appris
c'est la compassion
ces changements de vie il nous a appris
beaucoup de choses il ya eu évidemment
énormément de rire de chant de fête de
danse avec nos amis congolais
on a aussi partagé des pleurs mais parmi
les changements il ya déjà eu savoir se
détacher de ce qu'on croit indispensable
avant de partir en mission je discutais
avec une mère de famille de trois
enfants comme moi qui partait en mission
au cameroun et qui me dit dans notre
logement il y aura pas d'eau courante
pas d'eau courante mais il ya un an ça
vraiment je pourrais pas quoi bon
finalement on avait pas d'eau courante
on n'était pas prévenu mais on avait une
baignoire de 2700 kilomètres carrés pour
se laver le soir on apprend aussi à
lâcher prise
moi quand j'ai pris la direction du
réseau
on a énormément travaillé avec les
ip on avait très bon résultat c'était
très grisant très exaltant il y avait
des négociations passionnante au
national à l'international
et puis à un moment où j'ai dû
démissionner pour des raisons éthiques
et ça a été très douloureux mais j'ai
compris que j'étais pas indispensable
que tout ne dépendra pas de moi ça m'a
fait faire vraiment preuve d'humilité et
j'ai compris surtout que l'important ce
n'est pas d'avoir des grandes
responsabilités mais de rester en vérité
et puis on a découvert aussi
l'universalité de l'humanité quand on
voit les photos des réfugiés au kivu
ces gens là ils peuvent nous paraître
très très différentes nous très loin de
ce qu'on est nous et en fait on découvre
qu'un parent qui soit congolais qu'ils
soient français
tout ce qu'il veut pour son enfant c'est
le loger le nourrir les éduquer et
soigner quand il en a besoin
et puis la dernière leçon qu'on a
rapporté c'est que chaque journée est
une merveille quand on arrivait au
travail mes collaborateurs triés et il y
en a toujours un qui faisait cette
prière seigneur nous te rendons grâce de
nous avoir gardé en vie cette nuit et de
nous offrir cette nouvelle journée à
vivre
alors moi me réveillant ville matin
jusque là c'était tout ce qui a de plus
normal et en fait j'ai vraiment
découvert que chacune de ces journées
était un cadeau qu'il fallait savourer
et puis vous allez nous demander et vos
enfants comment est ce qu'ils ont vécu
tout ça je pense que pour eux comme pour
nous il ya eu énormément de moments
merveilleux avec leurs amis en fratrie
en famille il ya eu aussi des moments
difficiles mais pour vous istres
illustrer le changement chez eux
j'ai vous renvoyer à la rentrée 2010
vite donc on rentre à caen après deux
ans donc nos enfants en deux ans de plus
et donc le vélo d'élise 20 maintenant à
comme le vélo d'élise c'est un vrai vélo
deux filles
il est rose et donc comme arrive à la
rentrée pour retrouver ses copains et
ses copains lui disent tu as un vélo
deux filles et comme leur réponds bah en
fait il ya des millions d'enfants qui
rêve d'avoir un vélo alors on s'en fiche
bien qu'ils soient roses merci écrit
elle elle vous invite à une minute de
voyage à bukavu en vidéo
[Applaudissements]
je me rappelle ces jours de liesse
mon parti vert innocent tue t ch semble
pas fait ces vielles je me rappelle
c'est long chemin dans ton dos
feriez pas la fin
si tous rencontre au goût de miel devant
suppure cette mer si belle
j'me rappelle aux chansons de ses décors
restaurer
de nos sourires un ordre là
de ne pas
m
vagabond de nos a montré la hauteur
adieu coeur de ces chaînes
on retrouvera rien
patassé
adieu colère
adieu désir amer
côté
la folle
sincère
by avant
hamon
la faute à dieu que
pat a osé
adieu scolaire
adieu d illzach
[Musique]
pour la forme
passagère
[Musique]